So, of course, we have to talk about the Donald
Trump bleach injection fiasco that over the
weekend has turned from an offhanded, dumb
comment into really a catalyst of absolute
international shame, which has pushed Donald
Trump into hiding over the weekend in the
midst of a global pandemic, which he had mismanaged
from the get-go and is now set to surpass
this week the total number of deaths that
Donald Trump has been predicting. Donald Trump,
of course, talking about 60000 corona virus
deaths. The United States already as of right
now, at almost 56000. And every indication
that we will surpass that number this week.
And we have now this unforced error once again
of bleach injection. So please allow me some
time in today's show to really go through
some of the different elements of this and
to catch you up if you checked out of the
news altogether for the last 72 hours.
You may not have heard of this, but otherwise
you probably know that Donald Trump wondered
aloud in this tone, which he has perfected,
which is a tone that implies his ideas are
absolute genius. And how has not how has nobody
else thought of this stuff? Trump wondered
aloud, what if we injected disinfect? In fact,
it's like bleach and isopropyl alcohol, which
were the ones just previously in the press
briefing mentioned and put up on screen. What
if we introduce those into the body through
injection or some other means to treat Corona
virus? Now, of course, these are toxic chemicals.
They have large warning labels on them saying
this this can kill you, don't drink this,
don't ingest this in any way. Here's the source
of the insanity that kicked off the last three
or four days of madness.
Boy hits a body with a tremendous whether
it's ultraviolet or just very powerful light.
And I think you said that has a magic, but
you're going to test it. And then I said,
supposing you brought the light inside the
body, you can which you can do either through
the skin or in some other way. And I think
you said you're going to test that, too. Sounds
interesting. Right. And then I see the disinfectant
where it knocks it out in a minute. One minute.
And is there a way we can do something like
that by injection inside or or almost a cleaning?
Because you see it gets on the lungs and it
does a tremendous number. Will also be interesting
to check that so that you're going to have
to use medical doctors. But it sounds it sounds
interesting to me. So we'll see. But the whole
concept of the light, the way it goes it in
one minute, that's that's pretty powerful.
Absolute international embarrassment. We'll
discuss that international global shame momentarily.
Shockingly, or maybe not, Frumpkis immediately
started falling over themselves to defend
Donald Trump. Some started saying he never
said it. He simply never said it. Others suggesting,
well, it was a joke. Others saying it was
taken completely out of context. And unfortunately,
this is one of those cases where the more
context you get, the more clear it is that
it was accurately reported. Now, there are
people saying that Trump could have simply
met different disinfectants, like, for example,
he could have met medical grade anti-virals,
which disinfect the body or whatever. No.
Here is a picture that was on the screen moments
before Trump used the word.
It clearly says commonly available disinfectants,
bleach and isopropyl alcohol. Trump turns
around and talks about the disinfectants.
You're talking about putting them in the body
instead of using them to disinfect the desk,
for example. That's what he meant. So, of
course, he said it. Now, at one crazy moment,
Donald Trump turns to Dr. Deborah Brooks and
asks her, what about applying heat and light
to treat this?
Dr. Burke's in the way only she can as an
unfortunately growing vector of disinformation
for Donald Trump. She bails Trump out by saying,
well, there is this thing called fever. That's
sort of like heat in the body. Right. Check
it out.
I have to say, it covers a lot more territory
than just this. This is this is probably an
easy thing, relatively speaking, for you.
I would like you to speak to the medical doctors
to see if there's any way that you can apply
light and heat to cure.
You know, if you could and maybe you can,
maybe you can't. Again, they say maybe you
can. Maybe you can't.
I'm not a doctor. I'm like a person that has
a good. You know what? Have you ever have
you ever heard of that? The heat and the light
relative to certain viruses? Yes.
But relative to this virus, that is a that
certainly fever is a good thing. When you
have a fever, it helps your body response,
but not as I've not seen.
I think that's a great way to look at. I mean,
it's OK.
And then here is Dr. Steven Hahn, the FDA
commissioner, having to. Answer questions
during an interview with CNN's Anderson Cooper
and Dr. Sanjay Gupta about this. If you are
watching, pay particularly close attention
to the expression the look on Dr. Sanjay Gupta
faces this insanity is going on. I will remind
you, this is not a simulation. This is not
a drill. This is real life.
Is there any evidence about taking a disinfectant
that's used, you know, on the table where
I'm sitting and using it internally? That
doesn't seem like a good idea from my. I mean,
am I wrong? Yes.
I think it's an excellent point. You're making
you. We certainly wouldn't want, as a physician,
someone to take matters in their own hands.
I think this is something that a patient would
want to talk to their physician about. And
and no, I certainly wouldn't recommend the
internal ingestion of a disinfectant. Again,
this is a conversation that occurs every day
in America between a patient and doctor. I've
been in that position. I'm sure Dr. Gupta
has as well. And it's really important that
we address them because people will ask those
questions of us.
Well, Doctor, I I just I think we should be
clear, though, that the idea of doing some
kind of U.V. light therapy, which is sometimes
used for local issues in the body, but not
for a widespread viral infection. And the
idea of injecting disinfectant. I mean, there's
no reason those questions may be getting asked,
but there's actually no merit to that. That
doesn't need to be studied. You can already
say that that doesn't work. Right.
And I think, Sanjay, that that that is exactly
what a patient would say to a doctor, and
that would be the answer of the medical experts
to anybody who answered that question.
Right. Questions like, should I inject bleach?
Are questions really meant for doctor and
patient? That's where those are. Thank you,
Dr. Hahn, for clear clearing that up. Absolutely
shocking. So the end result is that Donald
Trump, during Friday's press briefing, the
day after this took place, abruptly ended
it and walked out without answering a single
question. We learned that right before the
briefing, Trump staffers came out and they
tried to reposition CNN reporter Caitlin Collins
to the back of the room. Normally she sits
near the front.
Clearly, they were expecting her to ask about
this as she should, and the reporters agreed.
We decide where we sit. You don't decide where
it is that we sit. And after they refused
to switch places, after CNN reporter Caitlin
Collins refused to be pushed to the back of
the room, Donald Trump simply left without
taking a single question, something he's not
done since the start of the press briefings.
Take a look.
I truly do believe the day will soon come
when we will heal our land and we'll be able
to reopen America and put this great nation
back to work. Thank you.
It's further.
So typically when Trump wraps, you get 30
minutes, 60 minutes, sometimes even more of
Trump answering questions. Trump instead just
leaving now. A couple of other things. We'll
talk more about Trump being in hiding momentarily.
But Donald Trump has been hugely triggered
by all of this and we don't know what the
form or frequency of future briefings will
be. One was scheduled for today. We don't
know whether questions will be taken. We know
that people around Trump are telling him you're
doing yourself more harm than good with these.
This is not good. But in the meantime, notice
the degree to which simply quoting Trump verbatim
triggers his supporters. Over the weekend,
I got into a crazy back and forth on Twitter
with Dilbert cartoonist Scott Adams, who has
become a big vector of disinformation in defense
of Trump. And he ended up angrily blocking
me. You can look at look at the Twitter history
of it, if it's interesting to you. But he
was increasingly triggered merely by people
telling him, you're just denying what Trump
said. Here's the quote. Oh, it's missing context.
Here's more context. And it is exactly as
reported. Trump wondering aloud, what if we
take the disinfectant? You're talking about.
And put them into the body. Let's next discuss
Donald Trump in hiding